how do a collection of cells remember
anything how do biological systems
remember anything how is that akin to
the kind of memory we think of humans as
having within our big cognitive engine
yeah one of the ways to start thinking
about bioelectricity is to ask ourselves
where did neurons and all these cool
tricks that the brain uses to uh run
these amazing problem-solving abilities
on them basically an electrical Network
right where did that come from they did
just evolve you know up here out of
nowhere it must have evolved from
something and what it evolved from was a
much more ancient ability of cells to
form networks to solve other kinds of
problems for example to navigate
morphospace to control the body's shape
and so all of the components
of uh of neurons so so ion channels um
neurotransmitter Machinery electrical
synapses all this stuff is way older
than brains way older than neurons in
fact older than multicellularity and so
it was already even even bacterial
biofilms there's some beautiful work
from UCSD on on on brain-like Dynamics
and bacterial biofilms so Evolution
figured out very early on that
electrical networks are amazing at
having memories at integrating
information across distance at different
kinds of optimization tasks you know
image recognition and so on long before
there were brains can you actually step
back we'll return to it what is
bioelectricity what is biochemistry what
is what are electrical networks I think
a lot of the biology Community focuses
on
the chemicals as the signaling
mechanisms that make the whole thing
work you have
I think
to a large degree uniquely maybe you can
correct me on that have focused on the
bioelectricity which is using
electricity for signaling there's also
probably mechanical sure sure knocking
on the door
uh so what what what's the difference
and what's an electrical Network yeah so
I want to make sure and and kind of give
credit where credits do so so as far
back as 1903 and probably
um late 1800s already people were
thinking about the importance of
electrical phenomena in in life so I'm
for sure not the first person to stress
the importance of electricity people
there were there were waves of research
in the in the 30s in the 40s and then
again in the kind of uh 70s 80s and 90s
of of sort of the pioneers of
bioelectricity who did some amazing work
on all this I think I think what what
we've done that's new is to step away
from this idea that and I'll describe
what what the bioelectricity is is step
away from the idea that well here's
another piece of physics that you need
to keep track of to understand
physiology and development and to really
start looking at this as saying no this
is a a privileged computational layer
that gives you access to the actual
cognition of the tissue of basal
cognition so so merging that that
developmental biophysics with ideas and
cognition of computation and so on I
think I think that's what we've done
that's new but people have been talking
about bioelectricity for a really long
time and and so also I'll Define that so
um what happens is that uh if you have
uh if you have a single cell cell has a
membrane in that membrane are proteins
called ion channels and those proteins
allow charged molecules potassium sodium
chloride to go in and out under certain
circumstances and when there's an
imbalance of of those ions there becomes
a voltage gradient across that membrane
and so all cells all living cells try to
hold a particular kind of voltage uh
difference across the membrane and they
spend a lot of energy to do so when you
now now so so that's that's a single
cell when you have multiple cells that's
all sitting next to each other they can
communicate their voltage state to each
other via a number of different ways but
one of them is this thing called a gap
Junction which is basically like a
Little Submarine hash that's just kind
of docks right and the ions from one
side can flow to the other side and vice
versa so isn't it incredible that this
evolved
it's not it's not wild because that
didn't exist
correct this has to be this had to be
evolved and it had to be invented that's
right somebody invented electricity in
the in the ocean one of this is a good
event yeah so so I mean it is it is
incredible um the guy who discovered Gap
Junction's Warner Lowenstein I visited
him he was really old human being he
discovered because who really discovered
them live probably four billion years
ago good point so your your give credit
where credit is dude he rediscovered he
rediscovered uh Gap Junctions but um
when I visited him in in Woods Hole uh
maybe 20 years ago now uh he told me
that he was writing and unfortunately he
he passed away and I think this this
book never got written he was writing a
book on on Gap Junctions and
Consciousness and I think I think it
would have been a an Incredible Book
because because Gap junctures are magic
I'll explain why in a minute uh what
happens is that just imagine the thing
about both these ion channels and these
Gap Junctions is that many of them are
themselves voltage sensitive
so that's a voltage sensitive current
conductance that's a transistor and as
soon as you've invented one immediately
you now get access to from from this
platonic space of of mathematical truths
you get access to all of the cool things
that transistors do so now when you have
a network of cells not only do they do
they talk to each other but they can
send messages to each other and the
differences of voltage can propagate now
to neuroscientists this is old hat
because you see this in the brain right
this action potential is the you know
the electricity
um you can you can they have they have
these awesome movies where you can take
a zebra like a transparent animal like a
zebrafish you could literally look down
and you can see all the all the firings
as the fish is like making decisions
about what to eat and things like this
right it's amazing well your whole body
is doing that all the time just much
slower so there are very few things that
neurons do that other cells that all the
cells in your body don't do they all
they all do very similar things just on
a much slower time scale and whereas
your brain is thinking about thing how
to uh solve problems in
three-dimensional space the cell else in
embryo are thinking about how to solve
problems in anatomical space they're
trying to have memories like hey how
many fingers are we supposed to have
well how many do we have now what do we
do to get from here to there that's the
kind of problems they're thinking about
and the reason that Gap Junctions are
magic is Imagine right from the from the
from the earliest from the earliest time
I'm here are two cells this cell uh how
can they communicate well well the
simple version is this cell could send a
chemical a chemical signal it floats
over and it hits a receptor on this cell
right
because it comes from outside this cell
can very easily tell that that came from
outside it's this is whatever
information is coming that's not my
information that information is coming
from the outside so I can I can trust it
I can ignore it I can do various things
with it whatever but I know it comes
from the outside now imagine instead
that you have two cells with a gap
Junction between them something happens
let's say the cell gets poked there's a
calcium Spike the calcium Spike or
whatever small molecule signal
propagates through the Gap Junction to
the cell there's no ownership metadata
on that signal this cell does not know
now that it's didn't that it came from
outside because it looks exactly like
its own memories would have looked like
of being of being of whatever had
happened right so Gap Junctions to some
extent wipe ownership information on
data which means that if I can't if if
you and I are sharing memories and we
can't quite tell who the memories belong
to that's the beginning of a mind melt
that's the beginning of a scale up of
cognition from here's me and here's you
two no now there's just us so they
enforce the collective intelligence
that's our Gap Junction that's right it
helps it's the beginning it's not the
the whole story by any means but it's
the start where's State stored
of the system so there are some is it in
part in the Gap Junctions themselves is
it in the cells there are many many
layers to this as always in biology so
there are
um uh chemical networks so for example
Gene regulatory networks right which
which are or basically any kind of
chemical pathway where different
chemicals activate and repress each
other they can store memories so in a
dynamical system sense they can store
memories they can they can get into
stable states that are hard to pull them
out of right so that's that becomes once
they get in that's a memory a permanent
memory so or a semi-permanent memory of
something that's happened there are
cytoskeletal structures right that are
physically they store they store
memories in physical configuration there
are uh electrical memories like
flip-flops where there is no physical
right so so if you look I I show my
students this example as a flip-flop and
the reason that it stores a zero one is
not because some some uh piece of the
hardware moved it's because there's a
there's a cycling of the current in one
side of the thing if I come over and I
hold
um you know I hold the other side to uh
to a high voltage for for you know a
brief period of time it flips over and
now it's here but the heart none of the
hardware move the information is in a
stable dynamical sense and if you were
to x-ray the thing you couldn't tell me
if it was zero or one because all you
would see is where the hardware is you
wouldn't see the the energetic state of
the system so there are also so there
are biological um states that are held
in that exact way like like volatile Ram
basically like in the in the electrical
status it's very akin to
the different ways the memory is stored
in a computer
so there's Ram there's hard drive you
can make that mapping right so I think
the interesting thing is that based on
the biology we can have a more
sophisticated you know I think we can
revise some of our some of our um
Computer Engineering methods because
there are some interesting things that
biology does we haven't done yet but but
you can but that map but that mapping is
not bad I mean I think it works in many
ways yeah I wonder because I mean the
way we build computers at the root of
computer science is the idea of proof of
correctness we program things to be
perfect
reliable
you know this idea of resilience and
robustness to unknown conditions is not
as important so that's what biology is
really good at so I don't know what kind
of systems I don't know how we go from a
computer to a biological system in the
future yeah I think that you know you
know the thing about biology like is is
all about making really important
decisions really quickly on very limited
information I mean that's what biology
is all about you have to act you have to
act now that Stakes are very high and
you don't know most of what you need to
know to be perfect and so there's not
even an attempt to be to be perfect or
to get it right in any sense there are
just uh things like active inference
minimize surprise optimize uh some some
efficiency and and some things like this
that that guides the whole the whole
business I mentioned to uh Offline that
um somebody is a Affinity work is Andre
capathi and he's uh amongst many things
also uh writes occasionally a great blog
he came up with this idea I don't know
if he coined the term but of software
2.0 uh where the programming is done in
the space of configuring these
artificial neural networks
is there some sense in which that would
be the future of programming for us
humans where we're
less uh doing like python-like
programming and more
um
how would you how would that look like
but basically doing the hyper parameters
of something akin to a biological system
and watching it Go and keeping it
adjusting it and creating some kind of
feedback loop within the system so
corrects itself yeah and then we watch
it over time
accomplished the goals we wanted to
accomplish is that kind of the the dream
of the the dogs that you described in
the nature paper yeah yeah I mean that's
what you just painted is a very good um
description of our efforts at
regenerative medicine as a kind of
somatic Psychiatry so the idea is that
you're not you know you're not trying to
micromanage I mean think about the
limitations of of a lot of the medicines
today we try to interact down at the
level of Pathways right so so we're
trying to micromanage it what what's the
problem well one problem is that for
almost every medicine other than
antibiotics once you stop it the problem
comes right back you haven't fixed
anything you were addressing symptoms
you weren't actually curing anything
again except for antibiotics uh that's
one problem the other problem is you
have massive amount of side effects
because you were trying to interact at
the lowest level it's right it's like
I'm gonna you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
try to program this computer by changing
the the melting point of copper like
maybe you can do things that way but my
God it's hard to to program it right at
the hardware level so what what I think
we're we're starting to understand is
that and and by the way this goes back
to what you were saying before about uh
that we could have access to our
internal state right so people who
practice that kind of stuff right so
yoga and then biofeedback and those
those are all the people that uniformly
will say things like well the body has
an intelligence in the scenario like
those two sets overlap perfectly because
because that's exactly right because
once you once you start thinking about
it that way you realize that the better
locus of control is not always at the
lowest level this is why we don't all
program with a soldering iron right we
we we take advantage of of the high
level intelligences that are there which
means trying to figure out okay which of
your tissues can learn what can they
learn uh what you know why is it that um
certain drugs stop working after you
take them for a while with this
habituation right and so can we
understand habituation sensitization
associative learning and these kinds of
things in chemical Pathways we're going
to have a completely different way I
think
um we have a completely different way of
of using drugs and of medicine in
general when we start focusing on the
goal state States and on the
intelligence of our subsystems as
opposed to treating everything as if the
only path was micromanagement from
chemistry upwards